[Music]
that was a heck of a save chris right
now from the i-team cameras are not only
watching parts of downtown las vegas
they are listening
we know our city is one of the most
surveilled places in the entire country
now a new technology is helping catch
people in the act
the i-team's david charns got an
exclusive look at how this technology
works on fremont street
and also a warning you're going to hear
gunshots but it's all a simulation
reports of a gunman at this concert at
the fremont street
experience two years ago caused chaos
[Music]
but there was no emergency no gunman no
threat
enter shot point new technology watching
and listening
high above fremont these digital eyes
and ears can help find a shooter fast
and know if gunfire is a cause for panic
or a bogus scare our system will not
only detect the shot but we will confirm
that it's an actual shot
not a pop balloon not a car back firing
not a firecracker
while we're watching the show above 16
of these sensors are honed in
on what's happening below this view in
this image
is actually what's happening right now
nick jones says it's tech that has roots
at the department of defense
and now it's defending an integral part
of the vegas economy
because we can confirm that shot and
identify it within seconds
we can then notify and then activate the
camera
to capture that information at the
moment it's happening
even with background noise or during a
concert software can detect that sound
signature
and alert police overall there's
probably 400 cameras down here
and the cameras are great but we need
stuff
to help us identify when something
happens mark redden runs security here
although it won't stop it it lets us
know instantly
that we need to do something during a
shooting a mesh of sensors track that
sound
mapping it out like you see here cameras
immediately record
pinpointing where the shots are coming
from it's one of a kind technology
jones says could have helped
investigators on one october
we would have been able to tell security
only one shooter
shooting from this room he's
approximately at this floor
looking ahead redden hopes his
investment could lead to a downtown
network
all watching and listening for any
danger the more that we can get
connected in the better coverage we'll
have all over
jones tells us he hopes to deploy this
technology along the las vegas strip
and on other properties he says it could
even be put
on light poles as part of smart city
technology
all to prevent and deter future crime
and tragedy
along the strip tonight i'm david charns
8 news now